hey youtubers is Charlie so new Rick and
Morty is coming really soon but because
a lot of you might not have ever seen it
before in the season 3 trailer is in
black and white I wanted to play the
season 2 trailer just to give you a
better idea for the series then I'll
play the season 3 trailer right after it
so here we go hi Morty I'm Crimbo polish
Michael I'm an assassin I buy guns from
your grandpa issues
[Music]
gross and weird the hell is happening
this is healthy trust me
syan top anything Rick and Morty Sundays
at 11:30 p.m. so they should give you a
pretty good idea for the animation that
tone now here's the season 3 trailer
it's just that this one is in black and
white so I'll explain everything after
hey listen I know this is your world not
mine sooner I can get out the sooner I
can go back to taking big craps and you
can go back to some system on them oh
you are one driven rat it should be a
little more driven right yes yes yes
come on come on come on fresh fresh
fresh oh is this your friend don't worry
he died doing what he loved being a dumb
[ __ ] rat
[Music]
[Music]
so some of you are probably like what
the hell just happened so what this is
is it's Rick trying to escape from
intergalactic prison by gene splicing
himself with a hot dog way he turns
himself into a hot dog and starts
grafting parts onto himself to make
himself like this super being so that he
can get out at the end of season two he
was captured it was part of the big
serialized storyline so I'll try to
explain all that and especially if
you've never watched the series before
I'll give like a quick recap of season 1
season 2 and like what the hell is going
on with the series it is one of the most
insane animated series you've ever seen
so if you're looking for like a game of
Thrones level animated series but it's
made as a comedy then you have to start
watching this in all the episodes are on
Hulu right now so you can watch them for
free but it normally airs episodes on
Adult Swim so for those of you wondering
when the hell it's going to start airing
season 2 aired at the beginning of
December last year they said as of the
end of September this year a couple
months ago all the episodes have been
completed and Dan Harmon the producers
were hoping for an end-of-the-year
premiere so until we hear otherwise it's
going to drop sometime in December
christmas comes early and i will be
doing videos for the episodes so be sure
to subscribe to get everything
make sure you turn alerts on so you
don't miss out it is going to be awesome
fourteen episodes now if you've never
watched rick and morty before it's a
series that's loosely based on a Back to
the Future riff that Justin roiland
created then he Dan Harmon and Ryan
Ridley turned it into a bigger series it
had like a really short run for season 1
they expanded that to 10 episodes for
season 2 there are now 14 episodes
for season three so like it gets like a
little bit more popular each year but
the basic premise is that Rick is kind
of like this boozy Doc Brown character
but he's more inspired by Doctor Who and
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy so if
you've ever watched Doctor Who the rules
are essentially Doctor Who rules meaning
that they break the rules all the time
but it's a multiverse show Rick has a
portal gun that allows him to travel
between any universe that he wants to go
to so they use that as the premise for a
lot of different episodes where they
wind up destroying their own universe so
their backup plan is to just find
another universe that's almost like
theirs that was a really fun David
Cronenberg fly episode a lot of them are
themed after big sci-fi movies and TV
shows my favorite episodes are all from
season two Total Recall Lucas purging
now in the wedding squatchers which were
basically like the last two episodes of
season two so one of the funny things
about the series is that they try to
mess with your head they include little
easter eggs separately from the writers
the background animators will draw in
things - the backgrounds - Easter eggs
that the writers don't know about so
sometimes when Dan Harmon and the other
people are doing commentaries they'll
notice stuff that they didn't know about
when they were actually making the
episode they're like oh the animator
added that we didn't ask them to do that
like because they surface a lot of
stories from traveling the multiverse
their house sustains a lot of damage
it's been through a lot of adventures so
they just progressively make the house
look crappier and crappier as it takes
more hits rather than make it look new
again every single episode like they
would on Family Guy or The Simpsons so
they have a really strong sense of
continuity but most of the episodes are
standalone the loose running plotline
what y'all explain it like a theory
video is the intergalactic Empire
that's after Rick for the first two
seasons they eventually catch him at the
end of the second season and he has to
escape the problem with being one of the
most smartest people like Doctor Who in
the universe is that everybody's after
you and all Rick wants is to be left
alone
so he's something of a rebel in the eyes
of a galactic government the idea of
there being infinite numbers of everyone
because infinite universes is really
important so for each universe there is
a Rick in a morty it becomes a very big
story device in this ongoing Galactic
Empire storyline there's a group of
Rick's that band together to fight
against the government but they have
their own problems too they have a
secret base called The Citadel of Rick's
we learned about that during season one
so if you're watching the series for the
first time I would recommend that you
start with season 1 but I do think that
season 2 up the quality big-time
meeseeks and destroy' is probably one of
my favorite season 1 episodes one of the
things that makes it so much fun to
re-watch episodes is that Dan Harmon
says that they try to read it proof
their episodes just so that people who
pick at the backgrounds and look for
little details clues will be able to
find things so it rewards multiple
intense viewings and they did say that
there is a secret storyline like a
secret plot line that they haven't
revealed yet that goes beyond the
Galactic Empire so I'll probably do a
video for that next but if you have any
special Rick and Morty request videos
just let me know in the comments what
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my spider-man footage
breakdown from Brazil Comic Con and you
can click here for the guardians of the
galaxy 2 trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody what's that Bob I'll
see you guys tonight
you